Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. There are bad reviews and then there is the obituary that the gonzo journalist Hunter S. Thompson gave President Richard Nixon. If the right people had been in charge of Nixon's funeral, Thompson wrote, his casket would have been launched into one of those open sewage canals that empty into the ocean just south of Los Angeles. He was a swine of a man and a jabbering dupe of a president. Nixon was so crooked that he needed servants to help him screw his pants on every morning. Even his funeral was legal he was queer in the deepest way his body should have
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告节目、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。世上有糟糕的评论，然后还有“奇葩”记者亨特·S·汤普森（Hunter S. Thompson）对理查德·尼克松（Richard Nixon）总统的讣告。汤普森写道，如果合适的人掌管尼克松的葬礼，他的灵柩会被扔进洛杉矶南部通往海洋的露天污水渠之一。他是个猪狗不如的人，也是个喋喋不休、被人当枪使的总统。尼克松坏得骨子里流脓，以至于每天早晨都需要仆人帮他把裤子穿上。甚至连他的葬礼都合乎法律，他在最深层的意义上是个怪胎，他的遗体应该
been burned in a trash bin and as I read that I hear the laughter from top historian of modern America Dominic Sandbrook and Dominic you gave me that quote I'm not going to pretend I found it myself obviously a favorite of yours um and today's episode it's it's not on nixon per se but it's on watergate and nixon obviously lies at the absolute heart of that scandal um and i thought that maybe the best we've got had loads and loads of questions on this but i thought maybe the way to kick it off is with a friend of the show stephen Jensen, who asks, what is it about Watergate that has made the suffix gate synonymous with scandal? Compared to the alternatives, does it deserve the dubious honour of being the linguistic mother of all scandals? Well, that's a great question, Tom.
被烧毁在一个垃圾桶里。当我读到这段话时，我听到了现代美国顶级历史学家多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）的笑声。多米尼克，这段话是你提供的，我不会假装是我自己找到的，这显然是你的最爱，嗯。而今天的节目，它不是关于尼克松本身的，而是关于水门事件的，当然尼克松是那个丑闻的绝对核心，嗯。我想也许我们手头有大量关于此的问题，但我认为最好的切入方式也许是请一位节目的老朋友斯蒂芬·延森（Stephen Jensen），他问：水门事件究竟有什么特点，使得“门”（-gate）这个后缀成了丑闻的同义词？与其它替代方案相比，它是否配得上作为一切丑闻语言学之母的“殊荣”？嗯，这真是个好问题，汤姆。
As you know, I've been looking forward to doing this since we started this podcast. And just on the Hunter S. Thompson line, I used to get my students, we did a whole course on Nixon that ran all year. We had four hours every week just on Nixon Hunter S. Thompson line, I used to get my students, we did a whole course on Nixon that ran all year. We had four hours every week just on Nixon in their third year. And I used to get them to read that obituary and write kind of comments on it. Hunter S. Thompson actually travelled with Nixon in the 1972 election campaign. He wrote a book about it, didn't he? And they talked about...
如你所知，自从我们开始这个播客以来，我一直很期待做这一期。关于亨特·S·汤普森的那句话，我以前会让我的学生们——我们做过一整年关于尼克松的课程。我们每周都有四个小时专门讲尼克松。关于尼克松……在我学生大三的时候。我以前让他们读那篇讣告，并写下各种评论。亨特·S·汤普森实际上在1972年的竞选活动中与尼克松同行。他写了一本关于这的书，不是吗？他们谈论了……
Fear and loathing? Yeah, fear and loathing on the campaign trail. And they talked about American football. Hunter S. Thompson was astounded by nixon's knowledge of american football uh so they did have a little bit there was a little bit of common ground between the two of them um but stefan's question which is a great question nixon is at the core of watergate so part of it is the character is this extraordinary shakespearean character um that we'll be talking about in a second it's also because i think watergate is the first great tv scandal so it plays out live on american television
《恐惧与厌恶》（Fear and Loathing）？对，竞选中的恐惧与厌恶。他们谈论了美式足球。亨特·S·汤普森对尼克松对美式足球的精通感到震惊，所以他们之间确实有一些共同点。嗯，但是斯蒂芬的问题是个好问题，尼克松是水门事件的核心，所以部分原因在于他的性格，这个非凡的莎士比亚式的角色，我们稍后会讨论。这也是因为我认为水门事件是第一大电视丑闻，它在美国电视上现场直播。
often um the senate hearings are on tv every afternoon where soap operas used to be so there's this sense of this kind of melodrama and these extraordinary characters i mean we're going to come to some of these characters you know the the actual essence of the scandal is actually pretty small but it comes to consume this sort of almost Dickensian cast of kind of misfits and eccentrics and it's not the scandal it's the cover-up that's that's yeah although the scandal itself is a pretty good scandal I mean bugging you know your opponent's headquarters and actually it's also what the scandal reveals about the Nixon White House and Nixon's own bizarre and tortured psychology I mean I think that um I like to think that this uh this podcast is definitely the podcast for 70s political scandals so we've already done the Jeremy Thorpe yeah yeah which features dead dogs fruit machine magnets and all kinds of fruit machine magnets but it's it's I I mean, is as British as a carry-on film. It is.
通常，嗯，参议院听证会在每天下午肥皂剧曾经播出的时段在电视上播出，所以有一种情节剧的感觉，以及这些非凡的人物。我的意思是，我们要讲到其中一些人物，你知道，丑闻的实际本质其实很小，但它最终却聚集了一批几乎带有狄更斯色彩的古怪人物和怪咖。这不是丑闻，而是掩盖，对，尽管丑闻本身就是一个相当不错的丑闻，窃听你知道你对手的总部，事实上这也是丑闻所揭示的关于尼克松白宫和尼克松自己怪异且痛苦的心理。我的意思是，我认为，我喜欢认为这个播客绝对是关于70年代政治丑闻的播客，所以我们已经做过了杰里·索普（Jeremy Thorpe）的节目，对，对，其中包含死狗、水果机磁铁和各种水果机磁铁，但这太……我的意思是，它具有纯正的英国“Carry On”系列电影的风格。确实如此。
Whereas this, this is the scandal for imperial America. It is. And I guess that that's why it has the resonance that perhaps the Jeremy Thornton scandal doesn't. Well, it's the combination, actually, Tom. You're absolutely right. It is the climax of what political historians call the imperial presidency,
而这个，这是帝国美国的丑闻。确实是。我想这就是为什么它能产生杰里·索普丑闻所没有的共鸣。嗯，这其实是一种结合，汤姆。你完全说得对。这是政治历史学家所称的“帝国总统制”的高潮，
so the kind of Cold War presidency. But it's the combination of that with the humdrum everyday very human kind of almost petty resentments of nixon himself that drive the scandal i mean i've got so much to say about this but so much of it is about nixon because without nixon there is no watergate he's at the absolute center of it and and lying at the center is his background and his all his pent-up resentments so on that topic we have we have a question from james bagerley i hope i've pronounced
也就是某种冷战时期的总统制。但这是它与尼克松本人那种沉闷、日常、非常人性化且几乎微不足道的怨恨结合在一起，正是这些推动了丑闻的发展。关于这一点我有太多想说的，但其中很大一部分都与尼克松有关，因为没有尼克松就没有水门事件，他是绝对的中心，而其中心则是他的背景和所有压抑的怨恨。所以关于这个话题，我们有一个来自詹姆斯·巴格利（James Bagerley）的问题，希望我发音准确。
his name right how important is richard nixon's feeling of outsider status in understanding his actions and do you both agree effectively dominic do you agree that what links trump and nixon is that they're both driven by an anger towards a ruling class that will never truly accept them now I think we should just park the comparison with with Trump okay for now yeah that question about about Nixon's upbringing sense of himself as an outsider important uh it's very important and this is great because I can now launch into my hour-long prepared um uh biography of Richard Nixon so as I, I taught this course on Nixon that went all year. And the first thing I got the students to do, I used to say, well, we're not going to call him Nixon. We should call him Dick throughout. Because I really wanted them to empathize with Nixon,
理查德·尼克松的局外人情结对于理解他的行为有多重要？你们两个是否都认同，多米尼克，你是否认为将特朗普和尼克松联系在一起的是，他们都被一种对永远不会真正接受他们的统治阶级的愤怒所驱动？现在我认为我们应该先把与特朗普的对比放一边，好吧，先这样。嗯，关于尼克松的成长背景以及他作为局外人的自我认同的问题，重要吗？这非常重要，太棒了，因为我现在可以开始我那准备了一个小时的理查德·尼克松生平传记了。正如我所说，我教过这门关于尼克松的课，持续了一整年。我让学生做的第一件事就是，我说，好吧，我们不叫他尼克松。我们应该自始至终叫他“迪克”（Dick）。因为我真的希望他们能对尼克松产生共情，
also just amuse me in a very childish way. And I think getting inside, as I used to say to them, you've got to get inside Dick's head and um i thought i think that's absolutely crucial to understanding how the scandal played out so let's talk about nixon nixon is born in 1913 in a place called yorba linda california which is this scruffy um sort of nondescript edge of la kind of now a suburb but then kind of on the edge of la quite rural and he's absolutely one of those people that we talked about in our California podcast and again in our Silicon Valley podcast. He's a white Protestant, kind of Midwestern American stock.
同时也以一种非常幼稚的方式取悦我。正如我以前对他们所说的那样，你必须进入迪克的内心世界。我认为这对于理解丑闻如何演变绝对至关重要。所以我们来谈谈尼克松。尼克松于1913年出生于加利福尼亚州约巴林达（Yorba Linda），这是一个寒酸、有些平淡无奇的洛杉矶边缘地带，现在是个郊区，但当时在洛杉矶边缘，相当偏远。他绝对是我们之前在加利福尼亚播客中谈到的人之一，也是我们在硅谷播客中再次谈到的人。他是白人新教徒，属于中西部美国血统。
He's Quaker, isn't he? Middle American. He is a Quaker, and that's really important. And Quakers don't swear? They don't. They don't drink. They don't swear. They don't dance. They don't approve of kind of fun to put it bluntly so his parents frank and hannah they've moved from kind of the midwest and they are the classic kind of people who move to california and it doesn't quite work out everything goes wrong so they found a lemon ranch and it doesn't work they don't sell any lemons and then they found
他是贵格会教徒，对吧？美国中西部人。他是贵格会教徒，这非常重要。贵格会教徒不发誓？他们不发誓。他们不喝酒。他们不发誓。他们不跳舞。直白地说，他们不赞成任何乐趣。所以他的父母弗兰克（Frank）和汉娜（Hannah）从某种中西部搬来，他们是那种典型的搬到加利福尼亚却并不太顺利、一切都出了问题的人。所以他们买下一个柠檬农场，但没有成功，他们卖不出任何柠檬，然后他们又创办了
a grocery store and a garage in a kind of garage a gas station attached to it and it's really hard work and young richard has to get up at four o'clock and kind of load i don't know potatoes or whatever it is um so he grows up in relative poverty in this midwest in this quaker family uh midwestern stock in california there's this there's this sense of disappointment that hangs over them in the kind of 1910s 1920s 1930s he's one of multiple brothers you'd enjoy this time they're all named after well four of the five are named after english kings so there's harold arthur um richard and edward and then there's also donald who's so which richard is um is richard nixon named after richard the linehart presumably not rich no no no although that's a great comparison um or indeed richard the second no he's richard the linehart um so two of the brothers die of tuberculosis um harold and arthur and this kind
一家杂货店和一个附带的车库、加油站，工作非常辛苦，年轻的理查德不得不四点钟起床，搬运，我不知道是土豆还是别的什么。所以他在加利福尼亚中西部贵格会家庭的相对贫困中长大，在20世纪10年代、20年代、30年代，弥漫着一种挥之不去的失望感。他是好几个兄弟中的一个，你会喜欢这个时代的，他们的名字都以——五个里有四个是以英国国王的名字命名的，所以有哈罗德（Harold）、亚瑟（Arthur）、理查德和爱德华，然后还有唐纳德，所以哪个理查德是……理查德·尼克松是以狮心王理查德的名字命名的吗？大概不是吧。理查德……不，不，虽然这是一个很好的比较，或者说确实是第二位理查德。不，他是狮心王理查德。所以两个兄弟死于结核病，哈罗德和亚瑟，这在某种程度上
of hangs over the family it's quite a sort of grim environment nixon says in his memoirs his mother his mother his mother never hugged him or showed him any physical affection but he could see from her eyes that she loved him which i always think is a sort of very telling so a kind of classic upper class british well yes i suppose so except the difference is they're so poor so nixon is that classic is that classic thing he's very driven he's very bright he does very well at school and he's offered a scholarship, I think, or offered a place at Harvard. There's no doubt that he's very clever. I mean, this is where the Donald Trump comparison rather falls down. He can't take it up because he's needed at home to help.
笼罩着这个家庭，这是一个相当严酷的环境。尼克松在回忆录中说，他的母亲，他的母亲，他的母亲从未拥抱过他，也从未表现出任何身体上的亲昵，但他能从她的眼神中看出她爱他，我一直认为这是一种非常说明问题的细节——一种典型英国上流社会的……嗯，是的，我想是的，除了区别在于他们太穷了。所以尼克松就是那种经典的……他是那种典型的人物，他非常有进取心，非常聪明，在学校表现很好，而且我记得他获得了一项奖学金，或者说获得了哈佛大学的录取名额。毫无疑问他非常聪明。我的意思是，这就是唐纳德·特朗普的对比显得苍白的地方。但他无法接受，因为家里需要他留下帮忙。
And also because his brother is ill and his mum needs to look after the care and all this kind of thing. So Nixon goes to his local college, Whittier College. And right there you have the, you could almost say watergate starts right there he is um a bit of an outsider kind of a lower middle class kind of poor relatively poor kid although very bright he talks later on about the laughs and slights and snubs that he suffers when he's there he's not allowed he's not invited to join the top fraternity on campus who are called the Franklins. I think we talked about this right at the beginning of the podcast series with Trump and Caesar and all that stuff. So he found his own called the Orthogonians, the square shooters who are for the kind of outsiders. And right there you have this.
而且还因为他的兄弟生病了，他的妈妈需要照顾他等等诸如此类的事情。所以尼克松去了他当地的大学——惠蒂尔学院（Whittier College）。就在那里，你可以说水门事件就在那里开始了。他有点像个局外人，是个下中产阶级、相对贫困的孩子，尽管非常聪明。他后来谈到他在那里时遭受的嘲笑、冷遇和轻视。他不被允许，没有被邀请加入校园里顶尖的兄弟会，他们叫富兰克林（Franklins）。我想我们在播客系列的开头谈到过特朗普、恺撒和所有这些事情。所以他创立了自己的兄弟会，叫做正交会（Orthogonians），也就是那些为局外人准备的、直言不讳的人。就在那里，你有这个。
He's got that sense. I hate to say this, Tom tom but it's you and your your yachting shoes nixon richard nixon is a man who goes through life permanently in the wrong shoes um there's even a kennedy there's even a very famous story yeah the right ones that nixon is told to do a kennedy style photo op by his aides and he walks onto the beach and he's wearing his shoes are too smart he's wearing smart kind of office shoes when he should be wearing kind of you know deck shoes your yacht your yachting shoes so that that nags at him the whole time he actually does really well he goes to duke law school he goes into the navy he's a lieutenant he's presumably on a scholarship
他有那种感觉。我讨厌这么说，汤姆，但这就是你和你的游艇鞋。理查德·尼克松是一个一生都穿着错误鞋子的人。甚至还有一个肯尼迪……甚至有一个非常著名的故事，是的，尼克松被他的助手告知要摆出一个肯尼迪式的拍照姿势，他走到海滩上，却穿着……他的鞋子太正式了，当他应该穿那种，你知道的，船鞋、你的游艇鞋时，他却穿着正式的办公室皮鞋。所以这一直在困扰着他。他其实做得很好，他去了杜克大学法学院，他加入了海军，他是一名中尉，他大概是有奖学金的。
yeah he's he's very bright. Everybody says he's hardworking. Interestingly, one of the things people say about him at this stage is he's honest. So he's not unpopular, but he's just an outsider. He's that classic heart. He has quite a good war, doesn't he? Yeah. He's a quartermaster in the Navy. So Quakers don't fight either.
对，他非常聪明。每个人都说他很努力。有趣的是，人们在这个阶段对他的评价之一是他是诚实的。所以他并不是不受欢迎，但他只是个局外人。他是那种典型的心灵。他度过了一段相当不错的战争岁月，对吧？对。他是海军的军需官。所以贵格会教徒也不打仗。
So he could have. Right. He overcomes that. And his Quakerism, I think, doesn't matter to him kind of theologically, as it were. I think it matters culturally. And I think there's always this sense of Nixon that he's a bit repressed. Somebody's always having more fun than he is and he's missing out. And it obviously becomes the Kennedys.
所以他本可以不去。对。他克服了这一点。我认为他的贵格会信仰从神学意义上来说对并不重要，但我觉得它在文化意义上很重要。而且我认为尼克松身上总有一种压抑感。总有人比他过得更开心，而他却错过了。这显然就变成了肯尼迪家族。
And you can absolutely see, I mean, we'll come back to this point, but you can absolutely see he is that classic you know that the self-made driven kid very bright who's conscious that he's missing out that other people have a grace and elegance and ease he's never going to be James Bond okay okay so so so just so he then he kind of gets into Republican yeah because he's a Quaker by the way he makes and he has to go into Republican. Yeah, because he's a Quaker, by the way. He makes, and he has to go into the Republican Party because he's a Protestant, because that's the thing that you do. Okay, so just this idea that the kind of guy who's looking up at the elite. Yeah. I mean, that's, I guess, kind of something that is a feature of the Republican Party now. But not then, you're right.
你可以完全看出，我的意思是，我们稍后会回到这一点，但你完全可以看出他是那种典型的——你知道那种白手起家、极具进取心的聪明孩子，他意识到自己错过了别人所拥有的优雅、从容和随性，他永远不会成为詹姆斯·邦德。好吧，好吧，所以……所以他后来加入了共和党，对，因为他顺便说一句是个贵格会教徒，他必须加入共和党。对，因为他顺便说一句是个贵格会教徒。他做出决定，他必须加入共和党，因为他是个新教徒，因为那是你应该做的事情。好吧，所以这种观点认为，这个家伙是在仰望精英。是的。我的意思是，我想这可以说是现在共和党的一个特征。但当时不是，你说得对。
Yeah, Nixon's one of the people who. So it it's unusual isn't it it's quite unusual he's and it's so so in a sense is he kind of i mean he's a he's a kind of portent of this idea that the deplorables are going to sign up to the republican a little bit yes a little bit he doesn't really emphasize that as much in the 1940s and 1950s but certainly later on um he's he's the man who coins the phrase the silent majority he talks again and again when he's president about the little guy the little man the common man all these kinds of things so absolutely he does that he's absolutely part of that kind of realignment and he's a big anti-communist yeah so here's an interesting thing nixon right from the start is regarded as a deplorable himself by the kind of patrician liberal kind of democratic elite he i think it's
对，尼克松是其中之一。所以这很不寻常，不是吗？这相当不寻常，他是……所以在某种程度上，他是否可以说是……他可以说是那种预示着“可悲者”（deplorables）将要加入共和党的人？有一点，是的，有一点。他在20世纪40年代和50年代并没有真正强调这一点，但到了后来，他确实……他是那个创造了“沉默的大多数”这个短语的人，他在担任总统期间一再谈到小人物、普通人、寻常百姓所有这些，所以他绝对这样做了。他绝对是那种政治重组的一部分，而且他是一个坚定的反共主义者。是的，这里有个有趣的事情，尼克松从一开始就被由贵族自由派组成的民主党精英视为什么？视为主流的“可悲者”。他，我认为这是
because california politics is pretty rough he uses anti-communism in 1946 and again in 1950 when he runs for the senate um he he always seems to there's this weird thing which i i he always seems to fight a little bit dirtier or to be a bit more competitive than everybody else. And it's not just a question of substance. It's a question of style, actually. So something that you would forgive in a more patrician who would then be able to make a joke about it afterwards. Nixon, there's always this stuff that he starts to be perceived quite early on as kind of dark, jowly, overaggressive. So there's a famous cartoonist of the 50s called Herblock who was always drawing him kind of climbing in or out of a sewer.
因为加州政治相当残酷，他在1946年和1950年竞选参议员时利用了反共产主义。他似乎……总是有一种奇怪的现象，我……他似乎总是比其他所有人斗争得更脏一点，或者说更有攻击性一点。这不仅仅是实质问题，实际上也是风格问题。因此，如果这种事发生在贵族阶层身上，人们会原谅他，事后还能拿它开玩笑。但对于尼克松，一直有这样一种情况：他很早就开始被视为那种阴暗、面颊下垂、极具攻击性的人。所以50年代有一位著名的漫画家叫赫布洛克（Herblock），他总是把尼克松画成爬进或爬出下水道的样子。
And then he really... So that's the thing that Thompson picks up on. Yes, and he really disgraces himself in the eyes of the sort of patrician liberals. In the early 1950s, when he exposes a genuine communist spy, a guy called Alger H hiss in the state department so i thought that was contested it used to be contested but it's not really contested anymore um sort of declassified soviet um archives show that beyond i think i would say reasonable doubt
然后他真的……这就是汤普森注意到的地方。是的，他在贵族自由派眼中彻底名誉扫地。在20世纪50年代初，当他在国务院揭露了一个真正的共产党间谍——一个叫阿尔杰·希斯（Alger Hiss）的人时。所以我想这曾是有争议的。过去是有争议的，但现在已经没什么争议了。某种解密的苏联档案表明，毫无疑问，我认为我会说超越合理怀疑
i mean some people would disagree but beyond reasonable doubt hiss was a fellow traveler probably a communist spy nixon exposes him in a very aggressive way and this is perceived as you know it's in for a dig it's not what you do alger hiss was one of us very well educated nice fellow you know lovely guest at a dinner party nixon's this god-awful hick from you know california um so so people hold that against him but that gets in the place as vice president to Eisenhower. But then when he gets that ticket, doesn't he then run into problems again? He does.
我的意思是，有些人可能会不同意，但毫无疑问，希斯是个同路人，很可能是个共产党间谍。尼克松以非常具有攻击性的方式揭露了他，这被认为，你知道，这很不地道，这不是你应该做的事。阿尔杰·希斯是我们自己人，受过良好教育，人很好，晚宴上可爱的客人。尼克松是来自加利福尼亚的那个糟糕透顶的乡巴佬。所以人们对此耿耿于怀，但这让他成为了艾森豪威尔的竞选搭档。但是当他拿到这个入场券时，他难道没有再次遇到麻烦吗？他遇到了。
There's some scandal. So this is a nothing scandal. It's a made-up scandal, really, that he has been profiting from a fund for Republican donors in California. But he had the essence of Nixon's appeal. Because what Nixon does, Nixon is terrified that Eisenhower is going to drop him from the ticket eisenhower world war ii general um because he thinks eisenhower has basically made it clear that he thinks of nixon as a kind of an ant beneath his shoe and that he's and he's batman yeah he despises nixon i mean he basically signs up to he's just nick he regards nixon as an unfortunate necessity um so nixon makes this unprecedented live tv address
有一些丑闻。所以这是一个无中生有的丑闻。这是一个编造的丑闻，实际上，说他从加利福尼亚的共和党捐赠者基金中获利。但他展现了尼克松吸引力的本质。因为尼克松所做的一切……尼克松吓坏了，担心艾森豪威尔会把他从竞选搭档中除名。艾森豪威尔是二战将军，因为他认为艾森豪威尔基本上已经明确表示，他认为尼克松就像脚底板下的一只蚂蚁，而且他是蝙蝠侠。对，他鄙视尼克松。我的意思是，他基本上认为尼克松只是一个不幸的必需品。所以尼克松发表了一场空前的电视直播演讲，
right okay so dominic and dominic in we mentioned the jeremy thorpe scandal yes which featured a dead dog yeah this features a live you've got to have a dog in every podcast right so this is a live dog nixon basically says there are two there are two great lines so one of them he basically says this is all nonsense there was a fund but I haven't profited from it. You know, it's perfectly legal, blah, blah, blah. He says, people, one of the most damaging allegations is that people say my wife, Pat, has got a mink coat. And he says, she has not got a mink coat. She has a respectable Republican cloth coat.
对，好吧，多米尼克，在……我们提到了杰里·索普的丑闻，对，其中有一只死狗，对，这次有一只活狗。你必须在每个播客里都养一只狗，对吧？所以这是一只活狗。尼克松基本上说，有两个……有两个伟大的台词。其中一个，他基本上说这全都是无稽之谈，确实有一个基金，但我没有从中获利。你知道，这完全是合法的，巴拉巴拉巴拉。他说，人们……最具破坏性的指控之一是人们说我的妻子帕特（Pat）有一件貂皮大衣。他说，她没有貂皮大衣。她有一件体面的共和党布面大衣。
And all across the land, people are saying, oh, hurrah for Nixon. Isn't this wonderful? And then he says, now, there is one gift that we have that we have taken he said somebody wrote in the newspaper that my girls trisha and julie and they wanted a dog and what did they send us in a box they sent us a lovely dog um and the girls called him checkers and the girls love the dog and whatever they say about it we're gonna keep it or something and of course you see high-minded tom hollandish people across america are vomiting into their waste paper baskets and salt of the earth dominic sandbrooks of wiping away manly tears and saying what a man what a family
而且在全国各地，人们都在说，哦，为尼克松欢呼吧。这难道不棒吗？然后他说，现在，我们有一份礼物，我们收下了，他说有人在报纸上写道，我的女儿特里夏和朱莉想要一只狗，他们用一个盒子给我们送来了什么？他们给我们送来了一只可爱的狗，嗯，女孩们叫他“查克斯”，女孩们很爱这只狗，不管别人怎么说，我们都要留着它或者别的什么，当然，你看，美国各地那些思想高尚的“托马斯·霍兰德式”的人正在往他们的废纸篓里呕吐，而像大地之盐般的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克斯则在擦拭着男子汉的眼泪，说“好样的，真是一个好家庭啊”。
so yeah so i think eisenhower was one of these people who's vomiting into a waste paper basket but he's forced his hand has been forced by n so Nixon then stays on as on the ticket um and then of course there's another great sort of crisis in Nixon's life uh so in 1960 he he basically inherits the Republican nomination from Eisenhower has he been a good vice president he's been all right actually yeah he's done more than any vice president before I mean eisenhower treats him like dirt throughout and tries to get rid of him in 1956 but nixon's like a sort of he's like a cockroach he can't be killed so nixon goes on trips and stuff and people throw stones at him in south america um and yeah presumably yeah so he kind of looks he's fine and he's right in the centre of the Republican Party. Standing up to communism. He's a moderate.
所以，是的，所以我认为艾森豪威尔就是那些正在往废纸篓里呕吐的人之一，但他的手被逼无奈了，尼克松的参选资格被保住了，所以尼克松留在了竞选名单上，嗯，然后当然，在尼克松的生活中又迎来了另一次重大危机，所以在1960年，他基本上从艾森豪威尔那里继承了共和党总统候选人的提名。他是一个好副总统吗？他其实还不错，是的，他做得比以往任何副总统都多。我的意思是，艾森豪威尔自始至终像对待垃圾一样对待他，并在1956年试图摆脱他，但尼克松就像某种蟑螂一样，根本死不了。所以尼克松去旅行什么的，人们在南美向他扔石头，嗯，而且是的，大概吧。所以他看起来还不错，他就在共和党的核心。挺身对抗共产主义。他是一个温和派。
He's actually not on the right. He's slap bang in this sort of centre. He'd fit perfectly into the Tory party of the 1950s, actually, in England. So he's the Republican candidate in 1960, and he's against basically his worst nightmare, an East Coast patrician, incredibly handsome. Who absolutely know the right shoes to wear yeah a man who's completely oversexed who's always wearing yachting shoes a man who'd won the
他其实并不在右翼。他恰好在这个中心位置。事实上，他完全可以融入20世纪50年代英国的保守党。所以他是1960年的共和党候选人，他的对手基本上是他的最大噩梦——一个东海岸的贵族，极其英俊。绝对知道该穿什么鞋，是的，一个彻底纵欲过度的人，总是穿着游艇鞋，一个赢得过...
pulitzer prize for something that is did somebody else had written for him a man whose father had got his mates to do his university thesis for him john f kennedy So a man who's got all the grace and elegance and all the connections, everything that Nixon hasn't got. And Kennedy wins by this very tight margin after a debate in which Nixon is perceived to have done better on radio and famously worse on television because he looks sweaty and kind of jowly and stuff. In his shadow.
普利策奖的人，虽然那是别人替他写的；一个父亲曾找朋友代写大学论文的人——约翰·肯尼迪。所以，一个拥有所有优雅、风度以及所有关系的人，这一切都是尼克松所没有的。而肯尼迪以微弱优势获胜，在此之前的一场辩论中，人们认为尼克松在广播里表现更好，而在电视上则出了名的糟糕，因为他看起来满头大汗、有些双下巴之类。生活在肯尼迪的阴影下。
Exactly. And what's worse, what's even worse for Nixon is that he could have won that election, actually. I mean, what I Nixon is that he could have won that election, actually. I mean, what I mean is he may well have won that election. But didn't Kennedy's daddy buy it? Right. There are allegations of vote stuffing in Illinois and in Texas. Maybe not enough, but enough for there to be a question mark. And Nixon doesn't contest the results unlike donald trump right so i was going
没错。更糟的是，对尼克松来说更糟的是，其实他本可以赢得那场选举。我的意思是，我说的是他很可能赢得了那场选举。但肯尼迪的爸爸不是花钱买下来的吗？没错。有指控称伊利诺伊州和德克萨斯州存在塞选票的现象。也许不多，但足以留下一个问号。而且尼克松不像唐纳德·特朗普那样对结果提出质疑，所以我要...
to say because because we we've already had the comparison um with uh with trump raised i mean that nixon doesn't contest it even though he thinks it might have happened for the good of the american republic yeah for the good of the american republic fair but well it's partly that it's also because partly around people around him are saying you know this is we're in the middle of the cold war you know this, you shouldn't really contest it. And it's not like he takes ages to make a decision. He doesn't. Straight away, he basically, or very quickly, he decides he's not going to contest it.
这么说是因为——因为我们已经拿他和特朗普做了比较，我意思是尼克松没有对结果提出质疑，尽管他认为这可能确实发生了，但他是为了美利坚共和国的利益，是的，为了美利坚共和国的利益。好吧，这算一个原因，但也部分是因为他身边的人说，你知道，我们正处于冷战时期，你知道，你不应该真的去质疑它。而且这并不是说他花了很长时间才做出决定。他没有。他基本上非常迅速地决定不予质疑。
And it is the right decision. It's the patriotic decision. Yeah, it is the patriotic decision. And I think it's also the right decision from his own sort of career point of view. Because, of course, he does then come back eight years later to become the Republican nominee in 1968. So he kind of sort of going off to become I mean, he does go off to become a New York lawyer, but his heart's not really in it. What he really wants to do is get back into politics. He has that.
这是一个正确的决定。这是一个爱国主义的决定。是的，这是一个爱国主义的决定。我认为从他个人的职业角度来看，这也是一个正确的决定。因为，当然，他随后在八年后的1968年卷土重来，成为了共和党总统候选人。所以他某种程度上离开了——我的意思是，他的确去当了一名纽约律师，但他的心思根本不在那上面。他真正想做的是重返政坛。他有那种……
He runs he runs for the governorship of California. He does in 1962. And it doesn't really work out. That doesn't go well. No. And at the end, and it doesn't really work out. And that doesn't go well. No, and at the end, he loses to Pat Brown. And at the end, he loses it with the press. And he says, you know, you've got what you wanted.
他竞选了加利福尼亚州州长。他在1962年参加了竞选。结果并不太顺利。那进展得不顺利。不。最后，结果并不太顺利。而且进展得很不顺利。不，最后，他输给了帕特·布朗。最后，他和媒体闹僵了。他说，你知道，你们得到了你们想要的。
Well, gentlemen, you won't have Nixon to kick around anymore. And they all say, oh, typical Nixon, such a bad loser. He's such a scumbag from Yorba Linda. Of course, he doesn't know how to behave. But that aside aside after that he then kind of slightly reinvents himself as the kind of sane center of the republican party so he basically just the context for this the context for this i guess going into 67 68 is the counterculture yeah protests against vietnam, hippies, all that kind of stuff. And he's a guy who wears business shoes to the beach.
好吧，先生们，你们以后再也无法拿尼克松当出气筒了。他们都说，哦，典型的尼克松，真是个输不起的人。他就是约巴林达来的一个败类。当然，他不知道该怎么表现。但抛开这些不谈，在那之后，他稍微把自己重新塑造成了共和党内理智的中坚力量。所以他基本上——这一切的背景是，进入67、68年时期的反文化运动，是的，抗议越南战争、嬉皮士、所有这些乱七八糟的事情。而他是一个去海滩还穿着商务皮鞋的人。
Yeah, exactly right. It's all about shoes. Shoes and dogs are what this podcast is all about. What we really specialise in. That's absolutely right. So America feels like it's unravelling. So it's the culture war. It's the first blast of the culture war as we would now recognise. A little bit, actually. Yes, a little bit. The Democrats are tearing themselves apart. Lyndon Johnson's been booted out because of Vietnam. of the culture war as we would now a little bit actually yes a little bit there were democrats are tearing themselves apart lyndon johnson's been sort of booted out because of vietnam uh
对，完全正确。这全都是关于鞋子。鞋子和狗就是这个播客的全部内容。这正是我们的专长所在。完全正确。所以美国感觉正在分崩离析。这就是文化战争。这是我们现在所认识的文化战争的第一次爆发。其实有点像。是的，有一点。民主党人正在四分五裂。林登·约翰逊因为越南问题而被赶下台。文化战争的初次爆发，其实有点像，是的，有一点，民主党人正在四分五裂，林登·约翰逊因为越南问题而被某种程度上赶下台，呃……
you're right that the the headlines are full of rioting the civil rights movement um has sort of passed its peak and martin luther king has been assassinated and then robert kennedy says and against that background nixon basically says you know I am the 50s in human form I am yeah look I promise law and order he says law and order again and again he says he has a secret plan to end the Vietnam war you won't tell anybody what it is but people say oh that sounds splendid yes um hurrah so he is elected quite a tight election but it's you know it's fine he gets in he gets in um and okay so yeah so he becomes president and i think it's time for another question this time from classicist who asks for most people nixon is synonymous with watergate and nothing else did he have any
你说得对，头条新闻到处都是骚乱，民权运动已经过了巅峰期，马丁·路德·金被暗杀了，然后罗伯特·肯尼迪说——在这种背景下，尼克松基本上说，你知道，我就是50年代的人形化身，我就是，看，我承诺恢复法律与秩序。他一遍又一遍地谈论法律与秩序，他说他有一个结束越南战争的秘密计划，他不告诉任何人具体是什么，但人们说，哦，听起来真棒，是的，万岁！所以他当选了，这是一场相当胶着的选举，但你知道，一切还好，他当选了，他成功入主白宫了。好了，那么他成为了总统，我想是时候提出另一个问题了，这次来自一位古典学者，他问：对大多数人来说，尼克松就是水门事件的代名词，除此之外别无他物。他在总统任期内是否有任何...
significant political achievements during his presidency that have been overlooked or ignored what would his legacy have been if watergate had never happened okay well that's that's a great question um so his presidency is very turbulent but you could argue quite successful so he takes office we get some moon landings doesn't he for a start that's not he must have enjoyed that because because that was a kind of it was a Kennedy thing yes he's unable to pocket yeah I think he has probably has slightly mixed feelings about it because everyone knows it's a Kennedy thing but you're right right. He does sort of... He congratulates the astronauts and stuff. Vietnam completely overshadows his first term,
被忽视或忽略的重大政治成就？如果水门事件从未发生，他的政治遗产会是什么？好吧，这是一个极好的问题。他的总统任期非常动荡，但你可以说相当成功。他一上台，我们就实现了登月，不是吗？首先，这不是……他一定很享受这个，因为那算是一个肯尼迪的项目。是的，他无法把功劳据为己有。我想他对此可能心情有些复杂，因为大家都知道这是肯尼迪的项目，但你说得对，他确实……他向宇航员等人表示祝贺。越南战争彻底掩盖了他的第一任期，
trying to pull out. I mean, basically, he escalates in order to get out by widening the war into Cambodia. Massive student protests throughout his whole first term. But actually, when you go through i mean i don't think i'm out on a limb here almost all historians of nixon's presidency would say this when you go through policy by policy he's actually pretty moderate so his ambition is to be and these are his kind of words with his aides the american disraeli a tory man with liberal measures and
他试图撤军。我的意思是，基本上，他为了脱身而升级了战争，将战火扩大到了柬埔寨。在他的整个第一任期内，都爆发了大规模的学生抗议活动。但实际上，当你回顾——我的意思是，我认为我的观点并不孤立，几乎所有研究尼克松总统任期的历史学家都会这么说——当你一项一项地审查政策时，他其实相当温和。因此，他的雄心是成为——这些是他与助手们交流时用的原话——“美利坚的迪斯雷利”，一个带着自由主义措施的托利党人，并且...
actually you can look at lots of things he thinks talks about having a guaranteed income which is a thing that people talk about now sort of left-wing idea uh and dominic hadn't he um i mean he'd been in favor of the civil rights yeah he's pretty moderate in the early 60s exactly he's pretty moderate on civil rights when it suits him he bangs the law and order drum and he sort of condemns radicals and all this kind of thing but by and large yes he is on the sort of moderate wing of the republican party on civil rights he's um keen on kind of the environment i mean he sort of moans and groans about it but he does it um he he goes to china well of course this is about to get into his foreign policy achievements are his big thing so he goes to moscow and he goes to beijing i mean amazing and lots of people say only nixon could have done this because he has the anti because the united states had had they recognized china up to that point no no relations so basically
实际上你可以看看很多事情，他考虑并谈论过实行有保障的收入，这是人们现在还在谈论的一种左翼观点，多米尼克，不是吗？我的意思是，他一直赞成民权，是的，他在60年代初相当温和。没错，当对他有利时，他在民权问题上相当温和。他大肆鼓吹法律与秩序，谴责激进分子以及诸如此类的事情，但总的来说，是的，他在民权问题上属于共和党内较为温和的一翼。他热衷于环保——我的意思是，他虽然对此发牢骚，但他确实去做了。他去了中国——当然，这就要说到他的外交政策成就了，这是他的重大手笔。所以他去了莫斯科，也去了北京。我的意思是，太惊人了！许多人说，只有尼克松才能做到这一点，因为他拥有反共资本——因为美国人在此之前承认过中国吗？没有，没有外交关系。所以基本上...
their relations were non-existent utterly non-existent because they'd recognize taiwan as legitimate exactly so he ditches them and gets into bed basically with... But I mean, the imagery. Nixon on the Great Wall of China. Nixon in Beijing... It's a great wall for great people. This is a great wall, as he says. Nixon kind of clinking glasses with Mao Zedong. I mean, that's extraordinary. And then he does the same with Brezhnev in Moscow.
他们的关系不存在，完全不存在，因为他们承认台湾是合法的。没错，所以他抛弃了台湾，基本上和……但是，那个意象。尼克松站在中国的长城上。尼克松在北京……长城是给伟大的人民修建的。这是一堵伟大的墙，正如他所说。尼克松与毛泽东碰杯。我的意思是，这太非同寻常了。然后他在莫斯科对勃列日涅夫做出了同样的举动。
So this is the heyday of detente. And he and Henry Kissinger, Secretary of State, work incredibly... I mean, this is basically their passion. They think they're reordering the world and actually they are. You know, Nixon's meeting with Mao is the moment
所以这是缓和政策的全盛时期。他和国务卿亨利·基辛格展开了难以置信的合作——我的意思是，这基本上是他们的最大热情所在。他们认为自己正在重塑世界，而实际上他们也确实做到了。你知道，尼克松与毛泽东的会面正是那一刻：
that China comes out of the cold. And if you stand right back from this, that's more significant than anything Eisenisenhower kennedy johnson did arguably i mean i know that american listeners will say oh the civil rights movement is the big story and of course in many ways it is for americans but in terms of world politics yeah nixon going to china is absolutely seismic um okay and is that that's in his first term yeah right so 72 he he wins re-election yeah so we're
中国走出了冷战。如果你退后一步来看，可以说这比艾森豪威尔、肯尼迪、约翰逊所做的任何事情都更有意义。我的意思是，我知道美国听众会说，“哦，民权运动才是最大的新闻”，当然在很多方面对美国人来说确实如此，但就世界政治而言，尼克松访问中国绝对是具有划时代意义的。好吧，那是他的第一任期内，对吧？所以72年他赢得了连任，是的，所以我们...
yet to get to actually watergate itself but right 72 let's just let's just but let's just go through what he does in his presence so 72 the democrats do a sort of they do a british labour party in 1983 so they nominate a very impressive and admirable man who is a ridiculous man to choose as your nominees they nominate a man called George McGovern. He was a bomber pilot in World War II. He's a historian. Tom, he's got a history PhD. He's a very admirable, decent guy,
还没讲到水门事件本身，但是没错，72年，让我们来回顾一下他在总统任期内所做的事情。所以在72年，民主党人搞了一次类似1983年英国工党的行动：他们提名了一位非常令人印象深刻、令人钦佩的人，但他却是一个极其糟糕的候选人选择。他们提名了一个名叫乔治·麦戈文的人。他是二战中的轰炸机飞行员。他是一位历史学家，汤姆，他拥有历史学博士学位。他是一个非常令人钦佩、正派的人，
but he's kind of on the liberal wing of the Democratic Party. He's the Michael Foot. He is the Michael Foot of American politics. And right from the moment they nominate him, it's obvious that Nixon is going to win. The Republicans call him the candidate for the three A's acid amnesty and abortion amnesty for world for vietnam war draft evaders um and nick and mcgovern never shakes the tag and which nixon wins this colossal landslide massive lands biggest republican landslide i think ever at that point and if you want a clue if rich Nixon's tortured psychology, it's this.
但他属于民主党内的自由派。他就是美国政坛的迈克尔·富特。从他们提名他的那一刻起，尼克松的胜利就已经是显而易见的了。共和党人称他为“三个A”的候选人——堕胎、特赦和大麻（Acid， amnesty and abortion），为越南战争逃兵提供特赦——而麦戈文始终无法摆脱这个标签。尼克松赢得了这场压倒性的巨大胜利，这是共和党历史上可以说是最大的一次压倒性胜利。如果你想了解理查德·尼克松饱受折磨的心理，那就是这个。
What does he do on the night of that landslide victory? He goes alone to his study in the White House and he kind of turns off all the lights except this desk light. So he's sitting like this sort of really kind of rubbishy 1950s, 1960s kind of classical soundtrack, imagining ships clashing in the storm. So he listens to that silent, kind of alone, head in his hands. And then he gets out a pad and he starts writing down what people will say about him, about his failures. So he writes writes the opposition line will be rn let down his party um all this stuff oh if only he'd known what people would write about i know it's dominic i dominic i think that's the perfect note on which to go and take a break
在取得压倒性胜利的那个夜晚，他做了什么？他独自一人来到白宫的书房，关掉了所有的灯，只留下一盏桌灯。所以他坐在那里，配上某种非常烂的、五六十年代风格的古典音轨，想象着风暴中战舰相撞的场景。他就这样默默地坐着，独自一人，双手抱头。然后他拿出一个本子，开始写下别人会如何评价他、评价他的失败。于是他写道，反对派的台词将是：rn让他的党派失望了……所有这些诸如此类的话。哦，要是他早知道人们会写些什么就好了。我知道，多米尼克，我认为这是一个完美的节点，我们可以去休息一下了。
okay so this episode is about watergate so far we haven't got to it's like you and scottish politics i know i know what thermopylae or whatever i know but that's fine i mean if needs be we can go into another episode that's that's i think we're clearly gonna have to do another episode so let's take a let's take a break and then when we come back um are you ready to to actually look i'm absolutely poised i'm i'm pumped okay brilliant okay fabulous when we get back, Watergate. Add free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets. Head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Our topic today is Watergate and in classic Rest Is History style. We've done half an episode and we're yet to mention it.
好了，这一集是关于水门事件的，到目前为止我们还没讲到它。这就像你和苏格兰政治一样。我知道，我知道，温泉关战役什么的，我都懂。不过没关系，如果有必要，我们可以录制另一集。我觉得我们显然得再录一集。所以我们休息一下，等我们回来时——你准备好真正开始讲了吗？我完全蓄势待发，我已经热血沸腾了。太棒了，好极了！等我们回来，水门事件。无广告收听、独家附赠节目以及提前购买现场门票。请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。我们今天的主题是水门事件，延续了《历史其余部分》一贯的风格：我们已经做了一半的节目，却还没提到它。
So, Dominic, Watergate. What is it? What's going on? So, right from the start of Nixon's presidency, his administration had started crossing the line in terms, as we said before the break, it's an era of intense domestic turbulence but it's also an era when they're in a war okay just on that the question from guillermo
所以，多米尼克，水门事件究竟是什么？是怎么回事？话说从尼克松总统任期的一开始，他的政府就已经开始越界了。正如我们在休息前所说的那样，这是一个国内局势极度动荡的时代，但同时这也是一个他们正深陷战争的时代。好吧，就这一点，吉列尔莫提出的问题是：
tay avalado we'll never get to watergate tom no no but this i think this ties in richard nixon's personality and anguishes have been storied and abused but how much was his seeming paranoia against his adversaries justified the us were on the height of radical mobilization by the early 70s um so is that the context is is nixon feeling yeah properly paranoid yeah i think it's not the 19 it's not the 1950s i think that's a reasonable point i mean even as henry kissinger famously said even paranoid people do have enemies um and uh they feel embattled at various points in his first term the white house is literally surrounded by student protesters so they can't really go out. And Washington is brought to a halt.
吉列尔莫·泰·阿瓦拉多（Guillermo Tay Avalado）说我们永远不会讲到水门事件，汤姆。不，不，但我觉得这与理查德·尼克松的性格和痛苦息息相关，这些一直以来都被津津乐道且过度解读。但是，他对政敌的所谓偏执，究竟在多大程度上是情有可原的？到70年代初，美国正处于激进动员的高峰期，所以，这就是背景吗？尼克松是真的感到……彻底的偏执吗？我觉得这不像是50年代，我认为这是一个合理的观点。正如亨利·基辛格那句名言所说，即使是偏执狂也有敌人。在第一任期的各个阶段，他们都感到腹背受敌，白宫 literalmente（字面意义上）被学生抗议者包围，以至于他们根本无法出门，华盛顿的运转也陷入了瘫痪。
There is some domestic terrorism by kind of far left groups like the Weathermen in the late 60s, early 70s. There are the Black Panthers. I mean, all these things are kind of exaggerated a little bit within the Nixon White House. There's John Lennon. Yes, and Elvis offering to help bring him down um so so yeah so so nixon um i think nixon genuinely feels that nixon and kissinger generally they they feel they're in a war and they also feel that they can't trust the people around them so from 1969 onwards both nixon and henry kissinger are are constantly putting
在60年代末和70年代初，像“气象员”（Weathermen）这样的极左翼组织搞了一些国内恐怖主义活动。还有黑豹党。我的意思是，所有这些事情在尼克松白宫内部都被稍微夸大了。还有约翰·列侬。是的，还有埃尔维斯（猫王）主动提出要帮忙搞垮他。所以，是的，所以尼克松——我认为尼克松真心觉得，尼克松和基辛格真心觉得，他们正处于战争之中。他们也觉得他们无法信任身边的人。因此从1969年开始，尼克松和亨利·基辛格都在不断地进行...
pressure on other people to find out who's leaking. They call for FBI wiretaps. Kissinger wants his own staff to be bugged to find out who's leaking to the press. And in 1970, the Nixon administration, there's some of his aides talk about setting up their own intelligence service within the White House. Not the FBI, not the CIA, but answerable only to Nixon and his aides that will basically, you know, survey their enemies, sort of do dirty tricks, all these kinds of things. And you get the first.
向其他人施压以查出是谁在泄密。他们要求联邦调查局进行窃听。基辛格希望自己的员工也被窃听，以查出是谁在向媒体泄密。而在1970年，尼克松政府的一些助手谈到要在白宫内部建立他们自己的情报机构。不是联邦调查局，不是中央情报局，而是只对尼克松和他的助手负责，基本上会，你知道的，监视他们的敌人，搞点小动作，所有这些事情。然后你就得到了第一个。
And how legal would that be? Very completely illegal. But of course, Nixon and his aides are saying to each other, the kind of people in Nixon's White House are really important. So they're not often traditional party political people. They're people he's brought with him from California. They're people who worked in TV or advertising. They're loyal just to Nixon, not to the party or not to...
那会有多合法？完全不合法。但当然，尼克松和他的助手们互相在说，尼克松白宫里的人真的很重要。所以他们通常不是传统的党派政治人物。他们是他从加州带过来的人。他们是曾在电视或广告界工作过的人。他们只对尼克松忠诚，而不是对党派或不对……
So who are the most significant? So his chief of staff is a man called H.R. Hulderman. So I think he's a former advertising man. He's loyal purely to Nixon. So this is kind of Praetorian Guard. Praetorian Guard. The Berlin Wall, as they're called. H.R. Hulderman, John Ehrlichman,
那么谁是最重要的呢？所以他的幕僚长是一个叫H.R.霍尔德曼的人。所以我想他以前是个广告人。他纯粹忠于尼克松。所以这有点像禁卫军。禁卫军。柏林墙，正如他们所被称呼的那样。H.R.霍尔德曼，约翰·埃尔利希曼，
who is his domestic policy chief, a guy called Charles Coulson, who everybody calls an evil genius, who basically goes around telling everybody he's an evil genius. Right, like Dominic Cummings. Right, exactly. Who's his political...
他的国内政策主管，一个叫查尔斯·库尔森的家伙，每个人都称他为邪恶天才，他基本上到处对每个人说他是个邪恶天才。没错，就像多米尼克·卡明斯。没错，完全是。他是他的政治……
Dr. Evil. Henry Kissinger,inger obviously is his national security advisor and a lot of these people don't have maybe not so much kissinger but the others don't have links to the traditional kind of press elite they're not part of that kind of what we in britain would call the westminster bubble they're outsiders okay and so again that is kind of a parallel with Trump. Well... To a degree. I mean, Trump brings in all kinds of odd people who... I suppose to some extent. But I mean, actually, this is...
邪恶博士。亨利·基辛格，显然是他的国家安全顾问，许多这样的人可能没有——也许基辛格没有那么多，但其他人没有与传统的那种新闻精英建立联系，他们不属于那种我们在英国称之为威斯敏斯特泡沫的东西，他们是局外人，好吧，所以这再次有点类似于特朗普。嗯……某种程度上。我的意思是，特朗普引进了各种各样奇怪的人……我想在某种程度上是这样。但我的意思是，实际上，这是……
Because some of these people are very bright people that Nixon has around him. They're bright, talented, self-made people. I mean, they're not the kind of flagrantly corrupt kind of characters. But in 1971, they do their first really big dirty trick the first antecedent of watergate which is there's been leaks from within there's been all these leaks about vietnam and a guy called daniel elsberg links the pentagon papers as they're called this huge
因为这些人中有一些是尼克松身边非常聪明的人。他们是聪明、有才华、白手起家的人。我的意思是，他们不是那种公然腐败的角色。但在1971年，他们制造了他们的第一次真正的重大恶作剧，也就是水门事件的先兆，那就是内部出现了泄密，关于越南有各种各样的泄密，一个叫丹尼尔·埃尔斯伯格的人泄露了所谓的五角大楼文件，这是一份巨大的
tranche of documents about vietnam to show the government has been lying about vietnam for years but you know going back to kind of kennedy and johnson he leaks it to the press kissinger and um nixon say this is utterly intolerable and they get a unit within the white house who call themselves the plumbers because their job is to stop leaks and the plumbers burgle daniel ellsberg's psychiatrist in i think it's los angeles to look for documents that will smear him and that's the first real serious criminality I would say and and does Nixon know what they're doing well this is the question we don't really know but I think it's I think Nixon definitely not in a wing Nixon undoubtedly knows that something's going on because we know that throughout 1971 he is
关于越南的文件，显示政府多年来一直在对越南撒谎，但你知道，可以追溯到肯尼迪和约翰逊，他把它泄露给了媒体，基辛格和嗯尼克松说这简直是不可容忍的，他们在白宫内部成立了一个小组，自称为“水管工”，因为他们的工作就是阻止泄密，水管工潜入了丹尼尔·埃尔斯伯格的精神病医生的办公室，我想是在洛杉矶，去寻找会抹黑他的文件，我认为这是第一次真正严重的犯罪行为，尼克松知道他们在做什么吗？这就是问题所在，我们真的不知道，但我认为，我认为尼克松绝对不在局外。尼克松无疑知道发生了什么，因为我们知道在整个1971年他都在
haranguing his men and saying i need you to find dirt on the opposition i need to go in and he comes obsessed with this one think tank in washington called the brookings institution which still exists he tells them again and again i want you to get in there and blow the safe and find out what they've got i mean at one point they the brookings is what of the yeah of this at one point they cook up a scheme what's what's why is he so he and find out what they've got i mean at one point they the brookings what of the yeah of this think tank at one point they cook up a scheme what's what's why is he so he doesn't know what they've got but he thinks it might be interesting so um so at one point listen to this at one point they're gonna he says why don't you firebomb it they have this plan to firebomb it and then they'll all be dressed as firefighters and they'll run in steal all the documents and run out again so plumbers and firemen yeah um and the guys he's got doing this are bonkers so one guy is called howard hunt he was in the cia and he was one of the orchestrators
斥责他的手下，并说我需要你们去寻找反对派的黑材料，我需要进去，他对华盛顿的一个智库着迷了，那个智库叫做布鲁金斯学会，现在仍然存在，他一遍又一遍地告诉他们，我想让你们进去，炸开保险箱，找出他们有什么，我的意思是，有一次他们——布鲁金斯学会是——什么？是的，这个——有一次他们炮制了一个计划，什么——为什么他这么——他不知道他们有什么，但他认为这可能很有趣，所以，所以有一次，听着这个，有一次他们要——他说，你为什么不把它炸了？他们有一个计划要炸毁它，然后他们都会穿得像消防员一样，跑进去，偷走所有的文件，然后再跑出来——所以又是水管工又是消防员，是啊，呃，他找来做这件事的人都是疯子，所以有一个家伙叫霍华德·亨特，他在中央情报局，他是20世纪60年代初猪湾惨案的策划者之一，所以这就是他，另一个人甚至——甚至更有趣，一个才华横溢的人，一个叫G·戈登·利迪的人，你知道这个人吗？他就是那个因此被钉死的人，对吧？是的，他最终被里根赦免了，我不记得了，他基本上——他是个纳粹，他现在已经死了，所以我可以这么说。所以当BBC为他们的水门事件纪录片拍摄他时，他让自己在他拥有的这个巨大的枪支收藏前被拍摄。有一个参与其中的人对我说，嗯，你可能会认为这很糟糕。在隔壁的房间里，他有所有类似纳粹的旗帜和莱妮·里芬斯塔尔的照片之类的东西。我的意思是，他绝对是个疯子。
of the bay of pigs shambles at the beginning of the 1960s so that's him the other man is even even more interesting man a brilliant man a man called g gordon liddy are you aware of this man he's the one who who gets nailed for it doesn't he yeah and he ends up being pardoned by reagan i can't remember he's basically he's a nazi he's dead now so i can say so when the bbc filmed him for their watergate documentary he had himself filmed um in front of this huge collection of guns that he owned. And somebody who was involved with that said to me, well, you should think that's bad. In the next room, he had all, like, Nazi flags and pictures of Lenny Riefenstahl and stuff. I mean, he's an absolute lunatic.
他在BBC的纪录片中对着镜头说，你知道，如果理查德·尼克松告诉我去暗杀某某殖民者，我随时准备去做。我在等许可。所以——所以你把尼克松描绘成一个温和的共和党人，是的，有着许多国内和外交政策的成功，我的意思是，显然是一个非常非常能干、聪明的人，他为什么要雇用一个纳粹？我的意思是，我知道——我知道亨特·S·汤普森反文化对这的回答：他是个法西斯分子，是的，但因为他是个法西斯分子，是的，但——但我的意思是，他听起来不——好吧，我认为戈登·利迪有点像个外在的怪人，他有他那种奇怪的疯狂——我的意思是，有一个故事说他开始在白宫播放纽伦堡集会的录像或类似的东西，试图——这不会引起人们的怀疑，我想人们只是认为他是个怪人，他们只是苦笑，你知道，我——我认为他们——因为剩下的那些人不是纳粹，他们一点也不像纳粹，他们实际上也是相当温和的共和党人，但这非常像《奇爱博士》，确实有点像，但利迪是——我的意思是——所以他们在闲逛，他们在尼克松白宫周围闲逛，然后总统竞选开始了，尼克松对他的手下说，因为尼克松相信要进行非常激烈的斗争，如果不是肮脏的斗争的话。他们一直在尼克松的白宫周围闲逛。总统竞选临近。尼克松对他的手下说，因为尼克松相信要进行非常激烈的斗争，哪怕是不择手段。尽管他一定知道他会击败政府。但是，汤姆，他很偏执。他觉得这一切总是被剥夺。
And he says on camera in the BBC documentary, you know, if Richard Nixon had told me to go and assassinate such and such a colonist, I was poised to do it. I was waiting for the okay so so you've given the sketch of nixon as a kind of moderate republican yeah with a with a lot of domestic and foreign policy successes to his name i mean clearly a very very able smart guy why is he employing a nazi i mean i know what i know what the counterculture of the hunter s thompson answer to that he's a fascist yeah but because he is a fascist yeah but but i mean he doesn't sound well i think gordon liddy is a bit of an out as eccentric and his and his sort of strange nuts i mean there is a story that he started showing footage of nuremberg rallies or something in the white house um trying for the will not raise eyebrows i think people just thought he's
他总是被东部财阀欺骗。就在1972年初，他说——我的意思是他的——连任总统委员会，正如他们所称的，他们实际上是CRP，但每个人现在都叫他们CREEP，因为他们只是那种，你知道的，太棒了，完全是，呃，他们正在开所有这些会议，尼克松说，你知道，我需要发现你们在进行非常艰难的斗争，你们在做艰难的事情。所以利迪和亨特有这个荒谬的计划，他们称之为“宝石行动”，我的意思是其中一些是荒谬的，他们要送——我想他们确实这么做了，他们送了——他们订购了一千个披萨，并把它们送到民主党全国委员会，还带了账单。
eccentric they kind of smirked you know i i think they because i mean the rest of them aren't nazis they're nothing like nazis they're actually pretty moderate republicans as well but it's very dr strange it is a bit it is a bit but lydia is uh i mean so so they're hanging around they're hanging around the the nixon white house and and the the presidential campaign comes around and nixon says to his men because nixon believes in fighting really hard if not dirty They're hanging around the Nixon White House. And the presidential campaign comes around. And Nixon says to his men, because Nixon believes in fighting really hard, if not dirty. Even though he must know that he's going to beat the government. But, Tom, he's paranoid. He feels it's always been taken away from him.
是的，完全是，只是为了让对方破产，对吧？简直荒谬。利迪还——我的意思是，利迪字面意思上走进一次会议说，我有一个计划，我要——嗯，在迈阿密租一艘游艇，让佛罗里达州最好的妓女在上面服务，然后我会把高级民主党人引诱到这个房子里或者别的什么地方，他们就会——这大概是在迎合那种黑暗的贵格会感觉，也许吧——好吧，尼克松不在那个会议上，公平地说，尼克松不在关于妓女的会议上，但你是对的，我认为——令人惊奇的是，当你听到尼克松的人谈论这件事时，就像他们在后来的纪录片中所做的那样，他们不仅说，这绝对荒谬，我们都高兴得尿裤子了。他们认真考虑了其中一些想法。他们允许利迪和亨特这两个小丑继续，你知道的，在白宫附近走来走去，或者提出疯狂的计划。我的意思是，这有点像中央情报局暗杀卡斯特罗的所有计划。没错，爆炸雪茄。我简直不敢相信这些家伙是认真的。
He's always been cheated by the Eastern establishment. And right at the beginning of 1972, and he says i mean his the committee to re-elect the president as they call they're actually the crp but everybody calls them creep now because they're just kind of you know great exactly um they're having all these meetings and nixon says you know i need to find out that you're fighting really tough that you're doing tough things so so liddy and hunt have this ridiculous plans got operation gemstone they call it i mean some of it's absurd they're going to deliver i think they do do it they deliver they order a thousand pizzas and have them have them sent to the democratic national committee with a bill
记住，还有一个贝壳。他们会在海底放置一个爆炸的贝壳，让他去捡。还有，他们打算弄一种能让他的胡子掉光的粉末，这会在他的古巴粉丝面前羞辱他。是的，我的意思是，你简直不知道，人们到底是坐在会议里完全在开玩笑，还是真的认为这些都是好主意。不管怎样，反正基本上他们正在开所有的会议，然后他们想出了一个方案。他们要监听民主党全国委员会。
yeah exactly just to kind of bankrupt right just laughable lydie also i mean lydie literally goes into a meeting and says i have a plan to i'm going to um hire a houseboat in miami and have it and have it staffed by the finest prostitutes in florida and then i will lure senior democrats to this house or whatever and they will be which which which presumably is playing into the kind of the dark quaker sense of maybe yeah well nixon's not in the meeting to be fair nixon's not in the meeting about the prostitutes but you're right i think well the amazing thing is that when you hear the Nixon people talking about this, as they do and have done in documentaries since, they don't just say, this was absolutely laughable
现在，关于这一点最神奇的事情，对吧，就是在这一点上，很明显尼克松将以巨大的优势赢得选举。你知道的，他将轻松获胜。他本可以躺在床上。所以他不需要在床上躺六个月。他需要赢得选举。一切都是一团糟，他们闯入了民主党——好吧，好吧——所以就在我们真正做这件事之前，嗯，来自米格尔·德米尔的一个问题：总统对入室盗窃案有什么了解，他是什么时候知道的？所以——所以这是得到了尼克松的批准吗？我认为这极不可能。
and we're all wetting ourselves with amusement. They seriously consider some of these ideas. And they allow Liddy and Hunt, these clowns, to keep kind of, you know, walking around the White House or whatever, suggesting mad schemes. I mean, it's a bit like all the CIA plans to kill Castro. Right, the exploding cigar. I can't believe that these guys are serious.
我们不知道他在事前了解多少。他极不可能知道行动细节。另一方面，他很可能知道他们要做点什么。他知道他们没干好事。他正是那个一直在向他们讲述轰炸智库的人，所以他一直在向他们施压，他一直在向他们施压，压力无疑来自高层：你们在干什么？在某种程度上，这是一种奇怪的事情，在任何组织中，他们基本上只需要能够勾选一个方框，上面写着
Remember, there was a seashell. They would plant an exploding seashell on the sea bed that he would pick up. And there was also, they were going to get powder that would make his beard fall out, that would humiliate him in the eyes of his cuban fans yeah i mean you just don't know do you whether people are sitting around in meetings just completely taking the piss or whether they genuinely think these are good ideas anyway anyway so basically they're having all these meetings and they come up with a scheme. They're going to bug the Democratic National Committee.
已经轰炸了某人，已经订购了披萨，你知道的，是的，好让尼克松不再纠缠他们，因为他在烦他们。所以他们闯入了民主党全国委员会，在华盛顿一个阴暗的混凝土庞然大物里，那个地方叫水门大厦，它在华盛顿，而且出乎意料的是，他们安装的窃听器——他们通过地下的一种车库，大楼底部的车库闯入——而窃听器真的——我不知道，它们不管用，或者他们根本听不清任何声音。他们说，我们得回去重新安装窃听器。
Now, the amazing thing about this, right, is that at this point, it's pretty obvious that Nixon is going to win the election by a massive margin. You know, he's going to coast. He could just stay in bed. So he doesn't need to stay in bed for six months. He needs to win the election. Everything is a shambles they break into the democratic okay okay so so just just before we actually do this um a question from miguel de miel what did the president know about the break-in and when did he know it so is is so is this being licensed by n? I think it's highly unlikely.
所以在1972年6月17日，五个人——我Somewhere把他们的名字写下来了，如果你想知道他们是谁的话。他们是詹姆斯·麦科德、弗兰克·斯图吉斯、伯纳德·巴克尔、维吉利奥·冈萨雷斯和尤金尼奥·马丁内斯。所以他们基本上——他们的大多数人都是古巴人，他们是霍华德·亨特在负责猪湾古巴流亡者中央情报局事务时手下的人，他们某种程度上是真信徒，是的，他们有点像奇怪的古巴流亡者，在中央情报局边缘闲逛，极度
We don't know about how much he knows beforehand. It's highly unlikely that he knows operational details. On the other hand, it is likely that he knows they are going to do something. He knows they're up to no good. He is the very man who has been telling them about firebombing think tanks so he's been leaning on them he's been leaning on them the pressure is coming undoubtedly from the top what are you doing and in a way it's that weird thing where in any organization they just basically need to be able to tick a box that says
反共，极度反共，所以如果他们被告知他们是在为白宫工作，他们会很高兴的。于是他们闯了进去。然后就出现了一系列喜剧般的错误。所以门是那种自动关上的门，某种程度上是自动上锁的。所以他们必须在门栓上贴上美纹胶带。
have firebombed somebody have ordered pieces you know yes to get nixon off their case because he's pestering them so they break into the democratic national committee in this sort of grim concrete monolith called the watergate building um which is in washington which is in washington and surprise surprise the bugs that they plant this they break in through an underground kind of um car park the garage at the bottom of the building and the bugs don't really they I don't know, they don't work or they can't hear anything properly. And they say, we'll have to go back in and bug it again.
而保安，他是——叫什么名字来着？弗兰克·威尔斯，我想他叫这个名字。他发现了胶带，他想，哦，这太奇怪了，在大楼下方通往车库的门上，他把胶带撕掉了。他然后走开了。他们又潜了回来，把门和胶带恢复原状。他回来时，他们已经走了。他又发现了胶带，他觉得这真的很奇怪，于是他报警了。所以警察赶到了。他们逮捕了这五个家伙，带着对讲机。
So on the 17th of June, 1972, five men, I've got their names written down somewhere, if you'd like to know who they are. They are James McCord, Frank Sturgis, Bernard Barker, Virgilio Gonzalez, and Eugenio martinez so they're basically the majority of them are cubans they are people who worked for howard hunt when he was in charge of kind of bay of pigs cuban exile cia stuff they're kind of true believers yeah they're kind of weird kind of cuban exiles sort of hanging around on the fringe of the cia massively
然后发生的事情是，其中一个人在他的通讯录里有H.H.，霍华德·亨特，那个水管工之一。联邦调查局开始——他们觉得这很奇怪。这似乎是一起政治犯罪。他们基本上追踪了那个号码。他们发现，哦，这是一个白宫的号码。他们觉得这很奇怪。这似乎是一起政治犯罪。他们基本上追踪了那个号码。他们发现，哦，这是一个白宫的号码。这非常奇怪。所以在那个时候，有趣的点，有趣的问题，
anti-communist massively anti-communist so if they're told they're doing a job for the White House, they'll be delighted. So they break him. And then there's this kind of comedy of errors. So the doors are sort of self-closing doors, sort of self-locking. So they have to put masking tape over the kind of, the bolts.
有些人已经提出了，我懂的，就是在那个时候，尼克松能做什么？白宫能做什么？这是一个难题。所以在那之后的六天，发生了所谓的“确凿证据”的对话，因为当然尼克松在对自己进行录音，他继承了林登·约翰逊的录音系统。所以——为什么他要录下自己的谈话？别——汤姆，难道你没有录下你所有的谈话吗？嗯，我现在正在录，呃，不——不总是这样，为什么他要——我的意思是，这是一个非常好的问题，以前的
And the security guard, who was, what's his name? Frank Wills, I think his name is. He spots the tape and he thinks oh that's weird on the on the doors leading from the car the garage underneath the the building and he takes the tape off he then goes off they sneak back again and put the tape the door back again he comes back they've gone he spots the tape again he thinks this is really weird and he calls the police so the cops pitch up up. They arrest these five blokes, the walkie-talkies.
总统曾经尝试过录音——所以最明显的是林登·约翰逊——尼克松也这么做了，这是一种奇怪的自我保护，我想，如果我记录我的对话，它们就不能被用来对付我，我将对它们拥有控制权，人们将无法说出我没有说过的话，谁知道呢——我的意思是，那——我的意思是，这里面有一个致命的缺陷，不是吗？嗯，如果你说的话有极大的罪证，你必须确保不要说任何愚蠢的话，并且——在磁带上，我的意思是，实际上关于尼克松有趣的地方在于，我认为理查德·尼克松可能是——可能是历史上记录最详尽的人，天哪，因为即使在——现在在，呃，也许——也许社交媒体和——也许我不知道，我们有几个小时——我们没有
And what then happens is one of them in his address book has H.H., Howard Hunt, the guy who was one of the plumbers. And the FBI start to, they think this is weird. It's kind of some political crime. And they basically trace that number. And they're like, oh, it's a White House number they think this is weird. It's kind of some political crime. And they basically trace that number. And they're like, oh, it's a White House number. That's very weird. So at that point, the interesting point, the interesting question,
私人的，我想私人对话是没有的，那才是金矿，不是吗？但有趣的是，我们的对话完全是漫无边际、无关紧要的。我的意思是，有一些滑稽的对话。尼克松坐在那里，周围是他的“柏林墙”，正如他们所称的，霍尔德曼、埃尔利希曼、基辛格等等。通常他们只是在胡扯，这会让我们显得很有博学。我的意思是，他们的确是。尼克松有点在说——他们在谈论同性恋如何
which some people have raised, I know, is at that point, what can Nixon do? What can the White House do? It's a difficult one. So six days after that that there's what's called the smoking gun conversation because of course nixon is taping himself he's inherited a taping system from lyndon johnson so what why is he taping himself don't um don't you tape all your conversations tom well i am at the moment um not not always why is he i mean that's a really good question previous
导致了古德希腊的衰落。尼克松说他不会和任何来自旧金山的人握手，因为他们在谈论同性恋是如何导致古代希腊衰落的。尼克松说他不会和任何来自旧金山的人握手，因为他们都是同性恋。他们进行这些荒谬的对话，关于——哪个对电视或苏格拉底的影响更大，他们只是在胡扯——好问题，尼克松是——他们总是尼克松——他所有的——他也在他们面前稍微显摆，因为他总是有一种心态，他是那个想证明自己是个男子汉的书呆子学霸，所以他总是——他是总统，不是吗？是的，他总是试图显摆，说，你知道的——但他也试图表现得比现实中更具攻击性和反动性，我想。所以他说了很多反犹太的话，很多种族主义的话——嗯，我在其他语境下听到人们说，天哪，我简直不敢相信尼克松会说出那种话，因为他从来都不是那样的人——但我认为他是——这就像有人在进行板球巡回赛时——汤姆，不，不是在板球巡回赛上，而是在社交媒体上或别的地方在显摆。没错，他大部分时间都在这么做。但无论如何，呃，这有点扯远了。所以在1972年6月22日，他与他的幕僚长H.R.霍尔德曼进行了那次至关重要的对话。霍尔德曼基本上对他说，他问，水门事件现在进展得怎么样了？我认同这段对话的走向，你可以阅读文字记录，表明尼克松对这起入室盗窃案并没有太多的事先了解。他知道这是他的人，他在想：我们该怎么做来解决它？霍尔德曼说，嗯，情况不太妙，你知道，联邦调查局正在顺藤摸瓜，他们已经顺藤摸瓜查到了亨特和利迪，你知道的，这将会牵扯到白宫内部。尼克松说，好吧，这是我们可以关闭这件事的方法：我们将——你会打电话给中央情报局，中央情报局局长，你对他说，打电话给联邦调查局，告诉他们这是一个高度机密的、类似中央情报局的行动，涉及我们的古巴人。不要查下去。这是国家安全。这是一个巨大的烂摊子。
presidents had experimented with taping so lyndon johnson most obviously um nixon does it it's a weird kind of self-protection i think if i record my conversations they can't be used against me i'll have control over them people won't be able to say things that i haven't said um who knows i mean that's that's i mean there's a fatal flaw in that isn't there yeah well if you're saying something that's massively incriminating you just must make sure not to say anything stupid um and uh on the tapes i mean what what it means actually interestingly about nixon is i think richard nixon is probably possibly the most well-documented man who's ever lived in goodness because even even now in uh well maybe maybe social media and well maybe I don't know we have hours we don't have
这只是一团糟。这也是小题大做。这没什么。不要深入调查。就这样——这就是他的计划，而这当然是具有罪证的事情，因为这表明尼克松当时正在试图妨碍司法公正。这就是那场对话——那场对话的揭露，我们稍后会讲到——这才是真正让他倒台的原因，他立刻就知道并试图将调查扼杀在萌芽状态。好了，多米尼克，你刚才说稍后，我们——我想我们已经录了50分钟了，对吧？根据我的记录是43分钟。
private I suppose private conversations no that's the gold dust isn't it but the interesting thing is we have conversations that are utterly rambling inconsequential I mean there's some hilarious conversations. Nixon sits there with his sort of the Berlin Wall, as they're called, Haldeman, Ehrlichman, Kissinger, and so on. And often they're just wittering in a way that would make us look erudite. I mean, they are. Nixon is sort of saying they're talking about how homosexuality
43分钟。好吧，我想——我想我们应该在这里停下来，我认为我们应该在明天发布另一集后续节目。好的。当我们回来时，我们将看看掩盖真相的企图以及这一切是如何曝光的。是的。然后是赦免的过程以及水门事件的余波。酷。我很期待。我现在对明天的节目非常兴奋。
brought down ancient Greece. Nixon says he won't shake hands with anyone from San Francisco because they're talking about how homosexuality brought down ancient greece nixon says he won't shake hands with anyone from san francisco because they're all gay they have these ludicrous conversations about um which had more influence television or socrates um they're just sort of wittering good question and nixon is and they're always nick all his he's also slightly showing off to them because he's always got that thing of he's the school swat who wants to prove he's a kind of man's man so he's always he's the president isn't he yeah he's he's always kind of trying to show off and say you know but he's also trying to be more aggressive and reactionary i think than he is in reality so he says lots of anti-semitic things lots of racist things um which i which which people in other contexts have said
让我高兴的原因是，你刚才对我很粗鲁。因为我没有及时讲到温泉关战役和萨拉米斯战役。不，你没有。所以我感觉这很棒。但我们确实讲到了水门事件的入室盗窃。拜托，对我宽容一点吧。对，我们讲了。我们讲了。
god i can't believe nixon could have been saying that because he was never like that but i think he's so it's like someone going going on a cricket tour tom no not on a cricket tour on social media or something and showing off exactly that's exactly what he's doing a lot of the time but anyway um that's a bit of a sidetrack so on the 22nd of june 1972 he has the crucial conversation with hr hulderman his chief of staff hulderman basically says to him he says what's going on with the watergate thing now i think that the way this conversation goes you can read the transcript suggests that nixon didn't have a lot of prior knowledge of the burglary he knows they're his
是的，你讲了。你比我强。好了，谢谢大家收听这一集。我们明天会带着水门事件入室盗窃的余波回来，到时见，再见。感谢收听《历史余音》，如需收听独家剧集、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
guys and he's like what are we going to do to fix it and hulderman says well it's not great you know the fbi are tracing the leads they've traced them to they're tracing them to hunt and liddy you know it's going to come inside the white house and nixon says well okay here's how we can shut this thing down what we'll do is we will get we'll call this you call the CIA, the head of the CIA, and you say to him, call the FBI and tell him this is a top secret kind of CIA-ish operation involving our Cuban guys. Don't follow this. It's national security. It's a whole can of worms.
伙计们，他当时问我们该怎么解决这个问题，霍尔德曼说，情况不太妙，你知道的，联邦调查局正在追踪线索，线索指向了亨特和利迪，你知道的，这将会牵扯到白宫内部。尼克松说，好吧，我们这样来把这事压下去：我们给中央情报局局长打电话，你对他说，让联邦调查局别查了，就说这是一项最高机密的、带有中情局性质的行动，牵涉到我们那几个古巴人。别查下去了。这事关国家安全。这会捅大娄子的。
It's just a bit of a mess. It's also a storm in a teacup. It's nothing. Don't get into it. Just off that's his that's his plan and um and that of course is the incriminating thing because that shows that nixon is right then trying to obstruct justice and that's the conversation the revelation of that conversation which we'll get to later on that's what really brings him down the fact that he knew straight away and he tried to stop the investigation in its tracks okay dominic you said later on we've i think we've we've recorded 50 minutes worth have we 43 minutes according to my 43
这只是一团糟。这也是小题大做。这根本不算什么。别去管它。这就是他的计划，而这当然也是最能定罪的事情，因为这表明尼克松当时就在企图妨碍司法公正。正是这段对话——以及这段对话的曝光（我们稍后会讲到）——才真正彻底扳倒了他：他从一开始就知道真相，并试图彻底阻止调查。好了，多米尼克，你刚才说“稍后”，我想我们已经录了50分钟了吧？根据我的记录，是43分钟。
minutes okay well i reckon i reckon that this i think we should stop here and i think we should put out another episode to follow on tomorrow. Okay. And when we come back, we'll look at the attempts to cover up how it comes out. Yeah. And then how the process of the pardon and the afterlife of Watergate. Cool. I'm looking forward to it. I'm very excited about tomorrow's episode now.
43分钟，好吧。我觉得我们应该在这里停一下，然后明天再推出一期后续节目。好的。等我们回来时，我们将探讨掩盖真相的企图、真相是如何大白于天下的，以及随后的总统特赦过程和水门事件之后的余波。太好了，我很期待。我现在对明天的节目感到非常兴奋。
And the reason this pleases me is that you were very rude at me. Because I didn't get to the Battle of Thermopylae and Salamis in time. No, you didn't. So I feel it's great. But we did get to the Watergate break-in. Come on, give me a bit of slack. Yeah, we did. We did.
让我高兴的是，你刚才对我很不客气，因为我没能及时讲到温泉关之战和萨拉米斯之战。不，你确实没讲。所以我感觉这样很好。不过我们确实讲到了水门事件入室盗窃案。行了，对我也别太苛求了。对，我们讲了，我们确实讲了。
Yeah, you did. You're better than me. All right. So thanks for listening to this episode, guys. We will be back tomorrow with the uh the aftermath of the watergate break-in see you then bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，你讲了。你比我强。好了，谢谢大家收听本期节目。我们明天将带着水门事件入室盗窃案的余波回归，到时见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》（The Rest is History）。想要收听独家节目、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。